it is worth noting that cats have really
small lungs and if they fail to connect
with that prey and to take it down
quickly they give up so if you've got a
Long Head Start you're going to outrun
it my name is Mark elbrock I've been
studying mountain lions for 20 years and
I've been lucky enough to also work with
African lions and leopards today we're
going to be looking at big cat attacks
in movies and judging how real they are
[Music]
where they stand up to begin a wrestling
is actually real African lions will do
that when they engage in a fight
especially over territory or rights to a
pride Young Lions actually challenge old
Lions that's totally real and that old
Lions almost always have a set of scars
on their face from these territorial
disputes over time that's totally normal
to see an old lion without any scars
means that lion has been bred in
captivity
pause all of that sort of Rapid like
violence is
very real I would just point out too
that the skin of cats when you see them
they often look loose they're swiping
with these you know these weapons these
claws that can dig in an inch or more
and that loose skin is protecting them
the big Mane is protecting them so that
all is defenses to allow them to have
these violent exchanges
[Music]
there was a moment there where you saw
one go on to his back that's really
normal a cat in a defensive posture will
start to go onto its hot onto its back
to have four weapons pointing up they
are devastating because now if a
competitor comes on top of them they
just shred their underbelly with all the
vital organs it's amazing to have that
much realism in a cartoon so I'm gonna
give this thing an eight
this is a pet animal a pet tiger there
are more tigers in captivity in the U.S
alone than there are wild tigers in the
entire world and that's just a crazy
thing to ponder the ears were forward
you always watch the ears of cats and so
this was not a threatened animal it
wasn't an agitated animal it was just
chilling this does not seem fair
it's rock paper scissors there's nothing
more fair interesting idea to try to
drug the Tiger in fact I know people who
have tried this on wild animals they use
syringes and load them up with drugs
I've seen that work in the field so
that's real I mean real-ish but
depending what they're giving you
when you saw the the tiger chewing on
the seat we call those displacement
behaviors a lot of captive animals
exhibit sort of stress in different ways
and so they'll bite things they'll claw
things you know I'm gonna give this
movie
a five
nope the pattern here that there's sort
of black squares with dots in them and
that's really important to identifying a
jaguar and differentiating it from a
leopard which has no black dots in the
middle
come on
I've seen this movie so I know the
context of it and so I know that the
Jaguar is a pet the owner has trained
this cat to engage in wrestling matches
what a Jaguar wander into a bar to get a
raw steak or to engage people absolutely
not in fact Jaguars among all the big
cats have the least records of attacking
people in the wild it's almost unheard
of
if that were a real fight and the Jaguar
were truly to bite down it could quite
literally bite through his arm they have
tremendous biting power as compared to
other cats of similar size
I'm good to pet you now and you're not
going to eat me understood you know
Hollywood loves its noises and in this
case it has the Jaguar purring Jaguars
can roar but they cannot purr so that of
course is completely unrealistic I'm
gonna give this a
four it's got tremendous comedy and poor
Natural History
that's a real mountain lion kid all cats
are born with blue eyes the pigments
haven't started to develop in their in
their eyes yet you can see this kitten
has you know been handled plenty it's
it's not agitated it's ears are forward
it to me I would call that a smiling
Kitty
phone lines can't Roar so they were
often considered the largest of the
small cats an agitated mountain lion
would be hissing
and then they often they'll snort like
as they pull the air back into his again
oh my God
this is one of the the first Clips in
which we've seen a cat drop its head
and lowered the front half of its body
and that's exactly what a wildcat does
when it is preparing to pounce what
would a mountain lion really do if it
was defending its kittens it's all about
luster you know false charge you they
make noise it would be an incredibly
rare thing that they would actually make
contact because in a fight they are
vulnerable and the best thing for the
safety of their own kittens is to stay
alive
oh oh my God
I mean there's there's so much to talk
about the cat's enormous to Kevin and I
know Kevin Hart is not I'm a huge man so
a typical female especially in Southern
California is going to be like 80 pounds
that cat is huge compared compared to
what it should be
oh my God
how she even dropped to the ground and
let go of him is totally not mountain
lion when a cat attaches to something
it's attacking they do not let go like
they are attached and they'll go down
with their prey they've actually been
seen rolling off mountains attached to a
bighorn sheep or some other prey and
rolling together
a happy pen he's not jabbing it in the
jugular he's jabbing it in the shoulder
which would be you know the least
effective form of Defense the neck would
have been good or the eye people often
recommend if a cat is actually attacking
you go for the eye I'm gonna give this
one a five
African lions the largest ones are
almost as large as the largest Tigers
there are records of up to 600 pounds
but they exhibit extreme dimorphism and
and that's a fancy word for saying the
males are a lot bigger than the females
when I've been in the field and
confronted a lion
when they stand up their eyes are
essentially even with your chest which
is incredibly intimidating
and this is hard to watch this reminds
me of
the Revenant that had Leonardo DiCaprio
that bear scene was just brutal like in
its ferocity and this is I mean this is
the most realistic attack we've we've
seen his back they often go for the
spine you know big cats when they're
attacking any kind of prey and you
notice this lion is biting a lot we
haven't seen that in these other clips
lots of clawing which as I talked about
is more about wounding this is a lion
going for a kill this clip is as real as
it gets I'm going to give it a solid
eight and it loses two points and just
the impact on the person who was at the
receiving end you know the devastation
of that attack would have been lethal
what the hell but if you're scared
that beautiful death machine will do
what God made it to do this part of that
clip is
actually
real you know that if you keep showing
fear to a mountain lion or to another
big cat you're setting yourself up for
potentially dangerous situation you
never want to give a cat
the opportunity to what I call gain
momentum they'll become Bolder and
they'll continue to do whatever they're
doing to make you afraid most folks will
recommend you take two fast steps
towards it like you towards it and I'll
clap I'll snap my feet I'll be loud I'll
be aggressive and they'll usually just
be like whoa
and then they'll leave God you just
follow me wherever I go well he's
looking at you that's actually really
cool thing to talk about because cats
lock on their prey to get them to break
that focal lock is really important if
you were to ever be in an encounter with
a big cat which you can do by
yelling screaming doing something
surprising yeah here we go I'm getting
here
the sound at the end
it's so funny because it's the ringtone
on my phone because that is one of the
most overused popular sounds of mountain
lions I love the fact they talked about
fear we'll give it a six
the greatest
problem with Hollywood cat attacks are
the noises first off cats are completely
silent when they're hunting don't let
your prey know you're coming
when that tiger emerges and hits the
wolf that's actually a really important
thing to note about cat hunting is that
they use their bodies not just their
claws and their teeth sometimes if they
can get enough power behind themselves
just their weight alone can break the
neck of an animal
you should never run that's like
triggering the prey response in a large
carnivore you want to confront a large
cat that is confronting you if it's
threatening you you want to scare it but
let's just assume that you've you're
running you know you've made that
decision it is worth noting that cats
have really small lungs and that they
have these short births that's why
they're explosive when they hunt and if
they fail to connect with that prey and
to take it down quickly they give up so
if you've got a long head start and you
could get that cat to run for you know
half mile or so yeah you're you're gonna
outrun it because humans are actually
built for Marathon runs
there's no way he could stand up to
being clawed several times so cat claws
are protractable and that means that
when the cat is relaxed they're actually
sheathed you don't see the claws and
that keeps them razor sharp so that when
they
capture pray or swipe pray they
immediately cut in and cut lacerations
like sharp knives just one swipe of a
tiger's claw would completely debilitate
debilitate this guy I'm gonna give this
one a seven
come on
come on come on
[Music]
will a tiger defend
food from a potential scavenger
absolutely and lions too and mountain
lions too and leopards too they'll all
do that
has the Tiger's ears out to the side and
that is an uncomfortable animal that is
an agitated animal it is telling the
world in every way that it is very
unhappy with its current situation
I takes to water for safety right it
leaps off the boat and if the tiger were
locked on him
truly hunting him that probably wouldn't
have saved him because tiger swim and
swim quite well but in this case as I
mentioned the tiger didn't seem to be
locked on him I'm gonna give this clip
an eight because the CGI is amazing
people
[Applause]
that could happen I've seen mountain
lions kill bear cubs on a couple of
occasions in terms of like how it would
hunt in open terrain you know the most
similar
sort of scenario I've seen is in the far
south out in the Patagonia grasslands
and the mountain lion would be down low
using every bit of grass or Rock to get
as close as possible they wouldn't
betray their presence now if they
thought that prey was totally vulnerable
which a young bear might be then sure I
you'll see Cats nonchalantly approach
pray that cannot get away
actual Mountain line but that this is a
cat that is clearly uncomfortable and is
not as hunting
[Applause]
would a mountain lion confronted with a
an adult brown bear turn and flea
absolutely you know mountain lions will
always choose the exit rather than
engage unless they're cornered and that
gets me a little bit to talk about the
habitat here it's
totally open there's hardly any trees
it's a lot of rock this is actually not
great Cat Habitat at least in the north
where you have brown bears
because this is the domain of wolves and
wolves always have the upper hand in the
open and so cats when you look at their
distribution across North America
they're almost never found in these wide
open areas so we've got real mountain
lions real bears I'm still going to give
it a seven because the open terrain
doesn't really match my favorite big cat
attack scene from today would be from me
time part of my enjoyment of that clip
was how poorly it was done you know in
terms of CGI and and the interaction
between Kevin Hart's character and and
the actual mountain lion thanks so much
for watching and if you're feel lining
it please click on the video above
[Music]